the movie going public has said loud and
clear Nicholas Cage sucks and they might
not just be talking about his
performances Dracula if the box office
numbers for his latest theatrical outing
are any indication keep watching to find
out everything that went wrong with
Renfield after the failed launch of
their Dark Universe Universal Pictures
went back to the drawing board trying to
figure out the best way to utilize their
lineup of classic monsters in came Lee
wanal in 2020 releasing a stripped back
updated take on the Invisible Man to
both critical and Commercial Acclaim
with a budget of seven million dollars
the film went on to gross over 139
million dollars per the numbers It
ultimately had its run cut short due to
the early days of the covid-19 pandemic
which forced theaters to close following
the success of the Invisible Man it
became clear that Universal was
interested in taking risky genre-focused
approaches to their classic monster
flicks Universal chairwoman Donna
Langley said as much in 2020 while
speaking in a Hollywood Reporter
Roundtable saying we have gone back and
created an approach that filmmaker first
any budget range with no rules or
obligations to maintain a shared
Universe things began to look exciting
for Universal's revamped take on their
classic monsters the most logical
conclusion was to bring Dracula arguably
their most popular character back to the
big screen and who would be a better
blood-sucking vampire than Nicolas Cage
the oscar-winning actor headlines
Renfield a horror comedy that sees the
iconic vampire sidekick Renfield to take
the spotlight directed by the tomorrow
War director Chris McCabe the film
focuses on renfield's quest to break
away from his toxic relationship with
Dracula per deadline Universal's latest
opened with a 7.7 million dollar debut
coming in third place at the box office
with a 65 million dollar budget the film
is effectively Dead on Arrival making it
a bomb for Universal despite featuring
an All-Star cast and a compelling
premise Renfield didn't make an
impression on audiences here's why 2023
has been the year of horror Scream 6 and
Megan have both boasted Juggernaut box
office runs breaking in a over 160
million dollars worldwide even smaller
players Like Cocaine bear and knock at
the cabin have made noticeable dents
bringing in over 50 million dollars
globally on sensible budgets audiences
have shown up in droves for this year's
horror flicks yet Renfield didn't make
the cut why instead of Leaning into the
horror aspects of the film Universal
played up renfield's comedy pitching it
as both a buddy cop film and a dramedy
involving toxic relationships this
direction certainly didn't help the
picture as Studio comedies have been
nothing but Financial disappointments in
recent years as daring as Renfield was
it didn't stick The Landing critically
blooper critic Audrey Fox was mixed on
the film praising its lead performances
but pointing out its flawed execution
Fox wrote before driving home how the
film mishandled its subplot there are
kernels of a really interesting take on
the Dracula Mythos here and the Nicholas
on Nicholas violence ensures a film
that's at least enjoyable to watch the
better film would have focused solely on
Renfield and Dracula as they Duke out
their relationship or maybe it just a
pure Dracula film set in the modern day
audiences were frustrated with the film
as well giving it a middling b-minus
Cinema score while B range scores are
common for even the most financially
successful horror films it can't be
ignored how Renfield was cooked up as a
comedy when audiences think of Dracula
they likely expect some Thrills and
chills along the way Camp certainly
isn't out of fashion but it's clear that
Renfield should have focused more on the
talents of its lead stars and the rich
horrific world of Dracula the Nicholas
Holt and Nick Cage star made its debut
during an awkward weekend the R-rated
flick opened during the Super Mario
Brother movies second week effectively
reducing its potential while the Mario
flake primarily appeals to kids the film
holds cross-generational appeal and has
found a considerable following with
adults during its sophomore weekend
Mario walked away with 87 million
dollars domestically giving it the
second best weekend for an animated film
Mario notably took up over 4 300 screens
shrinking renfield's maximum output
while Mario may have cut into Renfield
yields profits it's the Pope's Exorcist
that was the final nail in the coffin
for Universal's latest the Russell Crowe
starring Pope's Exorcist came in at
second place walking away with 8.5
million dollars made on a slick budget
of 18 million dollars the film is on
track to make a nice chunk of profit for
Sony Pictures and Screen gems both
Renfield and the Pope's Exorcist are
gunning for the same audience yet the
crow film had two advantages its low
budget and emphasis on horror coming in
behind Renfield was John Wick chapter 4
which boasted 7.67 million dollars in
its fourth weekend ultimately there were
far more engaging and interesting films
at the multiplex than Renfield the
horror comedy would have been far more
successful in October where it would
have been a unique offering for
audiences who craved both laughs and
scares that being said renfield's
release feels deliberate as universal
obviously knew what they were in for
when they were releasing their horror
comedy just a week after their box
office Juggernaut Mario in a crowded
April it isn't surprising to see
Renfield falter mid-budget films don't
have the same weight nor the longevity
as they used to at the box office with a
more modest budget Renfield could have
had the same opening weekend and walked
away as a success Jeff Katz the producer
behind the Pope's Exorcist echoed
similar sentiments on Twitter saying the
moral of the story is that genre
pictures should generally only be made
for a smart price Katz wrote discussing
how Pope's Exorcist triumphed over
Renfield whole point is to be able to
hit singles and doubles and still
potentially come back for more popes
will be profitable for Sony entirely
because of this approach Renfield after
a disappointing first weekend will
stumble likely because of less than
Stellar word of mouth and mixed reviews
from critics a reigned in budget would
have helped the film boast more legs how
did a studio horror comedy hybrid get
green lit with a 65 million dollar
budget it's fair to suggest that a
decent chunk went to its three lead
Stars Nicholas Cage Nicholas Holt and
Aquafina for all its alleged star power
it's still wavered a decent amount of
the film's marketing focused on the
quirky casting of cages Dracula which
may have turned some viewer off as great
as Cage's cult is on the internet
audiences simply aren't showing up to
support the former a-lister the actors
meta made for Twitter unbearable weight
of massive Talent opened to a similar
number last year per the numbers failing
to make a splash as it stands cage isn't
the draw he used to be not even if he's
dressed up as Dracula
foreign